the biggest pieces are the biggest
beeshit BS specious hey it's getting
toward the end of the day hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to a special
edition of Abby's kitchen called the
ridiculous where I'm calling out the
biggest BS on the internet today's
episode was inspired by Forever 21's
trashbag idea to send Bing Atkins diet
bars with everybody's online orders as
if we need some kind of subtle reminder
to lose weight so on that theme today we
are taking down diet culture with some
of the grossest fat phobic products I
found online I am pissed number one on
the ridiculous
Macy's portions diet plates so this
piece of really got me fired up online
not gonna lie couldn't hold myself back
but basically obviously these products
have been designed with toxic diet
culture in mind as a way to kind of
bully yourself into consuming smaller
portions the line of dinnerware includes
a wine glass that says on the lips on
the hips a pasta dish that says all
Dante al dente an appetizer plate that
says finger food hands off and then of
course the biggest piece of the dinner
plate the piece de resistance that has
three beautiful rings skinny jeans aka
the portion that is this big favorite
jeans and then mom jeans
what douchebag man thought it up
honestly do you not even follow fashion
trends mom jeans are in and you don't
have to have birth to human to rock the
look second ladies can we notice that
these don't say dad jeans meaning of
course the dye culture is not
surprisingly a pretty good example of
patriarchy motherhood is already equated
with being less desirable less beautiful
damaged with a larger body being kind of
at the center of these assumptions back
to my moms dads and child pre friends if
you're gifted with a set of these plates
first of all cut the giver out of your
life then second of all fill those
plates to the brim with it ever your
body desires then smash the
none of them along with Macy's
unrealistic body standards and send me a
photo of the damage next number two
revolves that is not beautiful sweater
so much went wrong here
so this sweater which red being fat is
not beautiful it's an excuse was
supposed to be part of a collaboration
with Lena Dunham basically to talk a lot
about some of the horrible comments that
women received on social media and to
raise awareness and money for
cyberbullying under this creepiest quote
was the words at Loma in really small
lettering referencing that this was a
quote actually said Paloma L filler al
Sisler else s L sub else
both else's I can't read it
okay referencing that this was actually
a quote said to Paloma Axl serve I say
yes no I didn't say else
Setzer else Elsa why can't I say it say
it to me Elsa sir okay referencing that
this was actually a quote said to Paloma
alpha sir L filled it just google it
what would say what we're done hello sir
first of all it's terrible that any
human would say this to Paloma II sorry
Paloma I respect you I just can't say
her name whether to your face or behind
the kind of cowardly guys of the
Internet but ii revolve you up huge by
advertising the sweater on a sample size
model and only offering it up to size XL
i would call it a huge marketing flop at
best and another example of thin
privileged exploiting fatness and
co-opting body positivity for
capitalistic games next number three
urban outfitters eat less shirt oh this
is disgusting every donor it's just the
[ __ ] worst
these are the worst ideas now I'm all
about freedom of speech but I'm calling
this one out as like a straight-up hate
crime urban outfitters is an insensitive
piece of storm not only is Urban
Outfitters
a goldmine for bogus whoo wellness
products but now they're being
explicitly fat phobic this is literally
Urban Outfitters marketing tactic they
released some grossly offensive
insensitive clothing item the internet
freaks out they pull the clothing item
from their website and then they send
some pseudo apology tweet this
pro-anorexia t-shirt is just one example
of urban outfitters propensity for
making politically incorrect statements
they've also got their depression
t-shirt glorified drinking here their
Obama black color option as well as the
star david t-shirt reminiscent of what
Jews were forced to wear during the
Holocaust in concentration camps it's
totally done
honestly this is beyond inexcusable so
please fashionable friends do a girl a
favor and boycott the hell out of this
store it is gross gross gross and we
don't need none of it in this world
next number four the cheat day lunchbox
y'all know I am NOT a fan of the idea of
two days and if you want to hear more
about that you can pretty much watch any
of my videos but in short I don't like
the idea of cheat days because they
really assign a ton of moral value to
food and they insinuate that any other
way of eating is morally superior and
good and clean and really creates a
dichotomy between good food and bad food
the only thing more volatile than the
fact that this lunch box even exists is
the fact that it's being marketed
towards young impressionable girls it's
pink it's sparkly it's available at
Nordstrom Rack among other items that
young girls might want like gummy bears
and other pink kind of back to school
items new research actually suggests
that most girls start dieting around the
age of eight let that sink in folks
eight years old when I was 8 I was
jumping on my bed singing into my
hairbrush in the mirror along to wannabe
pretending I was Baby Spice but this is
where we're at right now folks and it's
scary moms please do not buy your
children these lunch boxes in fact if
you see this lunchbox or one like it
when you're with your child
use it as a teaching moment to talk
about diet culture health and every size
and feminism in general the only context
that a young child should have around
cheating is not copying off someone
else's spelling test next number five is
the happy fork now I'm all about making
sure you have a fork in your purse
because you never know when cake might
happen but I have a funny feeling that
this fork is not meant for cake the
happy fork which is anything but that
let's be honest toast the cringe-worthy
tagline eat slowly lose weight feel
great
puke poop is not part of the tagline I
just I added that part in because that's
how I feel honestly this feels more like
the anti utensil and that explicitly
aims to prevent food from getting into
your mouth so the happy utensils measure
things like how long you spend eating
what the pause is between your bites how
many bites you take etc and then it
vibrates when it determines that you're
eating too fast now I wholeheartedly
believe that wolfing down your meal
definitely makes it harder for you to
kind of tune into your body and listen
to your body's innate hunger and satiety
cues which is of course a really
important tenant of intuitive eating
however punishing yourself and tricking
yourself using these gimmicks and
external regulators will actually do a
lot more harm with our relationship with
food than any good now I try to eat
slowly and mindfully as often as I can
but my reality is a mom son this means
that's just not possible I think a lot
of moms out there can probably relate to
the fact that this thing would probably
be buzzing so aggressively more so than
your personal massager because you never
really know when your casual relaxing
sandwich lunch with your toddler is
going to turn into an absolute meltdown
because there's salmon touch their Peas
so yeah sometimes eat really fast
because I know that every quiet moment
of eating is a miracle from the heavens
that I am not worthy of enjoying for
very long also is it necessary to upload
the data from this device on to your
computer or phone so you can share it on
Twitter because that is a legit selling
feature of this product obsessing over
fork servings really does sound a bit
disorderly to me
and in my opinion is not gonna lead you
down a path towards becoming an ax to
ative eater also if I'm gonna spend $60
on a fork I want it to be made out of
gold come with some kind of bushi
container of caviar and not look like
something that might toddler with use so
on that note next and finally York a
safe time locking container described as
your impulse control tool
Time magazine suggests that this can
save you from yourself folks if you need
to lock up your own food you need to get
a grip The Epoch hue section of their
website states that the K safe was
developed based on some of the research
from top universities in the United
States that pre commitment and
self-control can increase the chances of
people meeting their goals so basically
these marketers have taken research that
has nothing to do with with diet success
and have used it to prove that this diet
tool will help you lose weight a box
that locks up your brownies by force is
not a good example of self-control and
in fact I would argue it's indicative of
the opposite where there is actual
legitimate research is for the benefit
of intuitive eating and a non diet
approach to food when you get rid of
that good food bad food mentality and
embracing all foods fits approach to
food having a cupcake on the counter
really isn't such a big deal anymore
honestly I have treats in my house all
the time and I don't feel the need to go
crazy I say save your $50.00 on this
really ugly looking bread basket
contraption and invest that money in
some really good books on intuitive
eating and healing your relationship of
food so you can check out my link in the
description for some of my favorite
resources so guys I hope you enjoyed
this video if you did be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
if you have seen any crazy wellness
related products online that you won't
need a review subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen bye
you
[Music]